[Music]
today's question comes from john in
california
john writes my wife and i are
approaching 60 and have been married for
30 years she's had a gambling problem
since we got married and it's getting
progressively worse she keeps promising
to quit but every month spends thousands
of dollars on her hobby
hobby i'm just going to underline that
one mark mark that number yeah
she has a job but never uses her income
toward our family expenses to add to the
mess we had a daughter that i believe to
be mine until she had a dna test that
showed we are not related so in a
nutshell our marriage is a long-term
sham
at this point i have zero interest in
finding a different wife so i see two
possible paths i'll go ahead and mark
that one
we can either divorce and split our net
worth with me possibly getting strapped
with alimony payments for the rest of my
life or i can put up with her nonsense
of slowly bleeding down our savings and
investments
from a practical point of view it may be
quote unquote cheaper to keep her
but i'd still have to deal with the
mental mess what would you do in my
situation john you're a freaking tragedy
wow it's like a country song it's like
two country songs
and you know i love how you just
completely painted yourself into the
corner and there's only two possible
scenarios out of this and both of them
you die exactly i mean it's likely i'm
gonna starve to death or or have a
psychotic break i'm going to absolutely
lose my mind or we're going to be
cheaper to keep her and i'm going to
tolerate you are making an excuse for
tolerating this all these years because
you had manned up and dealt with the
problems but in the last 30 freaking
years
every home is built with a door on it
john
every home
and if somebody's lying to you about the
whether you're kid they're stealing good
grief
yeah you got to deal with this asap and
uh
you gotta get me all fired up dude you
need to you need to answer the question
here's the question number one
a gambling problem is an addiction not a
hobby stop painting it with this milk
toast wet toast language it's an
addiction you're married to someone who
is struggling with an addiction number
two she's never used she has a job but
she never uses income towards her family
expenses that's your fault correct
number three
we have a daughter that i believe to be
mine my nut my marriage is a long-term
sham maybe
but if it is it's because you
participated in this long-term sham okay
i want you to look in the mirror none of
this is new information correct
at this point we have zero interest in
finding a different wife that is
completely irrelevant to the point that
you are worth more than living in a home
where somebody is using you as toilet
paper stop
stop
nonsense
you don't have to be interested in
finding a different wife you can be
interested in preserving your dignity
taking care of your mental and physical
health and helping your wife not deal
with her hobby but possibly get help
because she's ill
should we continue
you can at least you can divorce i'm
never gonna tell somebody to get
divorced but this is a mess you've been
cheated on you have been someone's
liquidating your money you need to go
see an attorney and or a marriage
counselor today is what i'm saying
here's the thing
people do stupid butt stuff absolutely
that are harmful to other people
and
if it happens to you once you know shame
on her it
happens to you twice
happens to you three times happens to be
four times shame on you happens to you
over 30 years since we got married shame
on you for not dealing with it right
and and so uh dave ramsey is shaming
someone oh brother
dadgum snowflakes um but the uh the deal
is this it is your fault that you
haven't dealt with this before now
correct and so and you act like you're
somehow stuck you're not stuck no that's
the
the title of my new book own your past
change your future thanks for the
underhand pitch here john from
california you've got to own what is and
what is is you've allowed this you've
allowed yourself to participate in
somebody else's
illness or their addiction or their bad
behavior whatever you want to call it
for 30 years so tell me john on this
what i read is this lady is messed up
and he's almost as messed up as she is
yes so i have
it's hard for me to be hopeful that both
of them can come around
she has
why would she change her life her life
is fantastic she can do whatever she
wants whatever she wants whenever she
wants with no consequence and and he
just looks at her she lives in a
rent-free home wines and [ __ ] someone
else pays her food and what it never
does anything about it yeah so here's
the deal i mean in other words he can
come in tomorrow and with the help of a
counselor say we're going to go to a
marriage counselor and in order for me
to stay here's what has to happen
an ultimatum okay no more gambling and
your money becomes our money and um
anymore anything that looks or smells
anything like infidelity we're done
right i mean these are non-negotiables
he could come in tomorrow and then she
could say
um oh you're right after 30 years of
doing it this way i'm just going to stop
tomorrow um
probably not right but here's what
here's what probably what is going to
happen
it's not a matter of him saying well
then i guess i have to do this what he
has to do is draw boundaries and then
she gets to choose do i want to be in a
relationship with him yeah and she's
already chosen that by the way that's
for 30 years she has right that she
doesn't that's right
so john you got to see these are two
lazy people
uh they're lazy and that they cannot
deal with their stuff yeah i was
intellectually or they're just so
traumatized yeah whatever the reason is
they're they're not dealing with their
stuff either one of them yeah is what
i'm seeing so i mean i just it's just
old voice good old boy stuff but anyway
yeah so
that's what i you you are going to if
you asking us what to do we would say
you're going to sit down with a
therapist and you're going to say these
are the conditions under which i stay or
you're going to just say i'm calling it
a day click out peace out and get an
attorney and to presuppose that you're
always going to pay alimony you probably
are after 30 years but that also is a
negotiation
and uh she probably wants free of you
and let me say this not tongue-in-cheek
john you don't know what going to bed
just going to sleep feels like without
medication
you don't know what it's like laughing
from your guts anymore you don't know
what it's like to be with just a group
of buddies and y'all are having a good
time
you've lost that sense of joy and what i
would tell you is you're approaching 60
you got 30 years left
you can choose from this point forward
to make those 30 years the best 30 years
of your 60 or you can choose to oh this
is
the point is both paths are going to be
hard choose which kind of hard you want
you want hardware you slowly drown or
you want hard where you slowly stand
back up you get to pick
yeah you get it is way past time to
stand up dude stand up john way past
time you stand up this breaks my heart
dave
how many couples
in the united states live like this you
know they're roommates but i hope people
are so funny after they get clear their
sense of humor comes back hey one guy
said he said i i got rid of fifty
thousand dollars worth of debt and i
said what'd you do how'd you do that and
he goes i divorced her oh gosh
you need better friends that's funny
we're not recommending divorce we're not
glamorizing it
that's funny